hello
welcome back welcome back to the podcast
i'm here again i made it another week
uh welcome everybody i hope if you're
here
listening slash watching you're having a
great
wonderful monday i hope uh you're
healthy and well
and maybe have a pet
to just like hold and pet for a little
bit because i don't
like no specific reason that's just kind
of always a good thing to have happen
uh i have with me my assistant today
mr marbles back on his floating orange
cloud
how you doing bud you know you were one
of the most requested
guests that i have on this show so
welcome my guy how you doing
what you've been up to working on any
big projects
okay just sniffing around that's fine i
you know
can't all do everything anyway i'm super
psyched to be back for another episode
of the podcast julen cass and i i
thought about doing a lot of different
things actually i was a bit overwhelmed
to be honest which is good i was
um you know i was rich with ideas
from you guys um flooding the comments
and our discord
after last week when i was basically
like hey help me with some ideas and you
guys were
you came through big time so there's a
lot of different uh
cool ideas to sift through and we landed
on a really fun one today so i'm excited
to do it
um first though this episode is brought
to you by squarespace guys if you're
thinking about building a website do a
squarespace
they make the process of building a
website just so incredibly easy
streamlined
and they give you all the tools to
really build the website of your dreams
and it really is a lot easier with
squarespace
than you might ever think building a
website would be so right now go to
squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com
jenna julian to save 10 off your
purchase
your first purchase of a website or
domain more on that later squarespace is
awesome also guys
stitch fix is another sponsor today an
online
personal styling service that tailors uh
style and clothing to you and your style
and fit
and they send it to you in a box all
right you get an
online stylist okay how fancy is that
right now head over to
stitch fix s-t-i-t-chfix.com
jenna julian and uh you get an extra 25
off when you keep everything in your box
also the links are down below for
sponsors
more again on those later uh
anyway so
i can't first of all
i'm excited because we have so i have
some good
i think i have some good content today
all right i think i have some truly good
content and
the what gives me comfort in saying
i have good content is the fact that
it's not my content so i know it's got
to be at least pretty good right because
it's not mine
it's mine it's mediocre i'm used to that
you're used to that we all know
but uh you guys are pitching in this
week
all right you know
we all got chores to do okay so you know
this is our household this podcast and
you know you guys
this week you stepped up and you did a
bunch of chores you took the trash out
you did the dishes
you unloaded the dishwasher you mowed
the lawn i don't know
you helped out so thank you
uh on twitter we posted something along
the lines of hey we're doing
a shark tank podcast but we want you
guys to be pitching
julian me your ideas
since i'm doing this solo i felt like
that would be a cool
actually someone in the discord
suggested it so i don't have their name
in front of me but if that was you thank
you so much for that idea really awesome
idea
to be honest and uh i'm psyched to do it
so basically the way it's gonna work is
uh pretty dang similar to
how it went the past except i'm the
shark and so is marble he is my honorary
shark you know
when they have like the special guest
you know
the special entrepreneur made
billionaire
rich guy who's just like hey look i
started this company and i invested in
this company and now i'm gonna be on
shark tank look at me everybody i got a
suit
that's marbles so uh
in front of me i have 10 different
pitches from you guys uh pitching me
your shark tank inventions actually i
don't know if we should we should
dink tank we're gonna call it dink tank
uh your
your ideas and businesses for a dink
tank uh
what i was saying earlier though uh i
don't know how many [ __ ] episodes
we've done
a billion episodes it feels like at
least
spanned many many years doing episodes
uh
and slowly you know you were if you were
here from the beginning you know that we
were on
little usb mics on a laptop and we have
graduated to you know an entire room
with a professional preamp and like we
sound pretty good i think and
you know but we still you know in even
most recent podcasts if we want to play
you some media
we're like holding our phones up and
being like okay listen to this video
it's really cool
i finally hopefully fingers crossed
figured out
uh not that it was even that hard just
took some effort figured out a way to
play some media on
uh on our preamp and have it play
through you know
the channels that you're listening to so
you're not listening to me holding up my
phone through a speaker
that was long-winded but uh tldr is
going to hopefully sound better
and also we'll have the videos playing
behind me because
uh in in the post for dink tank we asked
that you guys record
a video of your pitch and i said you
know it would be fun to
watch you guys pitch me your ideas so uh
that's what's gonna happen all right i'm
gonna sit back here
with uh you know my fellow shark and
we're gonna
we're just gonna watch your pitches okay
so we have ten pitches i think they're
gonna all be under two minutes
uh if you in first of all we got a ton
of them okay so we'll probably if this
goes well we'll probably do more
down the line uh a dink tank episodes i
like calling this dink tank i think
um so if you were one of the people who
submitted and you didn't get in
just know that we have logged these
emails that you sent us and
they might make it into future episodes
because we definitely got a lot
we got 10 here today so let's get
started okay let's jump into the shark
tank
the dink tank and uh
and watch some pitches
oh boy first one is gonna be a doozy i
already know it
all right here we go welcome to the dink
tank
hello sharks my name is jake bubble
stark and today i'll be asking you
for 280 000 plus 10 grand because i
rolled my car
in exchange for 20 equity and the chance
to work with me
and i will be pitching you the
opportunity of a lifetime
tired of playing games where you eat
[ __ ] every round letting your teammates
down
not everyone's a pro player but with
pogchamp the scented candle tm pending
you'll heighten your gaming skills
confirming you to be a faster
stronger and better gamer one lit and
you're winning roughly 117
but trust me it's worth it
wow order now pogchamp
okay uh well thank you mr jake
for being our first contestant in the
tank today
wow what an invention what a niche
invention that is
uh it's appropriate that i'm wearing my
twitch shirt so
it's a candle that apparently when you
light it it
enhances your gaming abilities
i have so many questions what's the
science behind this i wish i could ask
you these questions
what's the science behind this jake did
you just light a candle one time and
then you were owning and then that then
you decided
i mean it looks pretty great i bet it
smells good too
although i will say a lot of people who
game on a pc
right it gets kind of hot in that room
candle lit it might get even more hot
that's a fire hazard
what was the what was the asking price
let's start it over again one sec hello
sharks my name is jake
bubble stark and today i'll be asking
you for 280 000
plus 10 grand because i rolled my car in
exchange for 20
equity you ruled your car how did you
get here
oh no uh
all right so that's two what do you say
220
plus 10 230 000 for 10
kind of like we're going here and also i
like you know what i appreciate about
this pitch is that pog
that face uh on the candle that's a
that's an emote on twitch it's a global
emote on twitch
meaning that twitch owns the right to it
um
and you definitely don't j which i you
know i like that
i appreciate that gusto just going out
and grabbing something that's not yours
and repackaging it
that's my style right there you got a
deal i'm in
pogchamp candle let's let's go let's
make let's make some [ __ ] money baby
right that was what is
what is in your background okay moving
on thank you jake
okay here we go
hello shark julen of the j podcast my
name is ray
first time caller long time listener
hello ray i'm sure i'm not the only one
who has
trouble focusing on one thing at a time
when there's so many things
that i could be paying attention to it
just kind of gets it hard to focus
on certain things
brain gauge is basically
an experience maker for your little
brain and it's
oh that's me right
right there you could simultaneously
experience watching the movie stuck on
you
oh i like it at the same time listening
to music yeah at the same time
watching videos but you can do all of
that
while streaming minecraft on twitch
we're in the testing phase right now and
it's going pretty good
except like 30 to 45 percent of
participants are experiencing minor side
effects
frequent nosebleeds muscle spasms mood
swings
i don't want to talk about that stuff
but i mean like other than that
they're consuming a lot more media than
the normal person
and if you can invest like i don't know
like a million or something we can get
the ball rolling a million
and we can see where it goes um i'll
take my answer
off here thanks peace okay well a
million
listen i don't know who you think you're
talking to okay maybe marbles has a
million throwing around here
brain gauge all right let me first of
all let me tell you what i liked about
this pitch okay then i'll tell you what
i didn't like
i'll tell you what i like first i liked
that
you just went ahead and played out this
scenario for me
where you're implanting an electronic
device into my brain
i appreciate that and i think that's
very that's wise
there are very few downfalls to that uh
i think not enough people are inventing
things that go inside your brain
so props you know what i mean props
i like that part i like that you
animated your pitch i thought that was
very creative
you're a very talented animator and you
drew me i mean
brownie points if you want me to invest
and you include me in your pitch
you know well done now i want to invest
i don't like bloody noses i don't like
cottonmouth
those are some of the side effects that
you listed i'm nervous
about getting them
i don't know that that would be fun for
me to get those side effects
what do you think marble do you want
some side effects
huh do you want
you want some side effects do you
i don't think we can handle these side
effects so i want to know um
i'm just going to have to answer this
myself because you're not here live but
you know you're still in the testing
phase
there's a little bit of risk to that
you're involved in
something that go it's it's like it's
biotech right it goes into your
biology but it's tech it's similar to
that one um
episode of shark tank like way back in
like season one or two or that guy
like when it first started like i don't
know 10 years ago this guy's like
trying to market this bluetooth um it's
basically like one of the bluetooth
speakers for your ear
and it goes imp he's like yeah it
implants surgically implants into your
neck or whatever and then it just stays
there and then we change the battery
every 10
years or whatever the [ __ ] and
everyone's like you're [ __ ] mental
and get out of here like that's nuts
you're crazy
and the guy actually was pretty
terrifying because there was he wasn't
even laughing he was like no this i want
to be
i want to be surgically implanting
something into people's
bodies and think i mean imagine having
done that and then 10 years later you're
like i have this stupid 10 year old
bluetooth device in my neck
i can't get it out someone's probably
monitoring me
so it gives me those kind of vibes a
little bit
you ask for a million marble what do you
say what do you think a million is a
pretty good deal right
i mean think about it we're on the
ground floor here they're barely in the
testing phase
this thing could blow up all right
you're in brain gauge we're in
you got our money don't blow it
this is a great pitch all right
moving on to the next one
hello sharks oh i like your shirt have
you ever traveled
and forgot your toothbrush i have
actually haven't i don't even know what
a toothbrush is but those problems are
no longer
i give to you the teeth brush
yes the teeth brush the plural
of tooth with brush
now you may be thinking isn't that just
a
toothbrush no
no it's not oh yeah
it's not because it is a communal
toothbrush
okay everybody can use this toothbrush
okay that's nasty
denny's public restroom that's
disgusting it's right on the counter
you go to your public park
restroom it's right in there absolutely
rancid
okay you go to your
fraternity shared bathroom absolute mess
under the three red solo cups and wound
up ball of
blood here is the communal toothbrush
everybody can use this toothbrush
everybody
anybody anybody can use this dude
are you okay are you okay please
please
the kids are starving i lost my job i
just need somebody to buy this
toothbrush
okay all right i hear you i hear you
okay well first of all great pitch
i love it thank you for uh
explaining to me in all these different
scenarios where you can use the teeth
brush
uh so uh
am i buying that one is this a company
am i investing in your company i don't
know the deal here
uh i do like the idea that we're cutting
down on waste
okay i will say that if you put one
teeth brush
in say the lobby bathroom of an
apartment building
and it's it's for everyone think of how
few there are so many teeth
teeth that are going to be brushed with
so many less
previous toothbrushes and now with one
single teeth brush like you're
eliminating waste if 10 people use the
teeth brush you're eliminating
nine single toothbrushes that would have
eventually just been thrown in the trash
and
been added to the waste so i like
i'm concerned there are some medical
concerns here and some hygiene concerns
here
if someone disgusting
and sick used the teeth brush before me
and left it there and then i walked in
and used it wouldn't that pose
a threat to me
you know what it it is a concern of mine
so
here's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna give
you a counteroffer
okay i will invest in your teeth brush
company
but for every teeth brush we sell
i want a dollar okay this is a royalty
deal
okay and then also in addition to that
uh i want the shirt that you're wearing
please i would like it
i would like you to mail it to me
because i would like to wear it i enjoy
the shirt that you're wearing and i
would like to enjoy it on my body now
uh but props for coming up with teeth
brush you know this is another one of
these inventions that
it stems from something that we all know
and it just you re-wrap it a little bit
and i i like that i like that i like a
little bit of re-wrapping here
so thank you i don't know if i caught
your name i don't but thank you
i hope your kids are okay
uh well moving on next pitch
what do we got here
hello sharks my name is dean goldberry
and i have the product for you i bet you
like coffee
i know i don't but i bet you do and i
bet you also like jacuzzis and drinking
your own bath water
okay i wish i could combine
all three of my favorite things well
dream no more with the coffee koozie
that's right our scientists have found a
way to get coffee
oh they have scientists so you can drink
your own filth water through beads
our scientists have developed a drawer
nice you pour your favorite coffee
ground
okay you shut it and you press a button
and it sends scalding hot coffee out
we tested it on 10 people and only eight
of them screamed so it's not
that hot it's only about okay 30 degrees
fahrenheit all right
but have you ever sat there and thought
i could deal with a burn i have thought
that exact thought
yes this is your opportunity at only six
payments of
565 dollars we can make your dream a
reality
i'm asking for forty five thousand
dollars okay
uh in exchange for point
one percent of the company but you can
also have
a coffee koozie for yours i can have my
own one thank you sharks wow
dean listen i'm excited about this offer
don't pay attention to any of these
other sharks i want you to look at me
okay
i like your salesmanship i like the idea
that you've come up with there are so
many things i like about this all right
i enjoy coffee
i enjoy koozies i also
you know you said eight out of the ten
people that you tested this on
screamed those might have been happy
screams
people scream when they're happy okay i
scream sometimes when i'm happy
we all scream for ice cream and
coffee koozies so yes some of them could
have been really burned and
potentially like permanently injured
from this experiment
but you do have scientists so you have
your you clearly
are a responsible adult and you're
covering your ass here
man i i've always wanted to become a cup
of coffee
and i think this is now the opportunity
to do that i will say that equity is a
bit low
0.1 percent for a lot of money
but i do get my own coffee koozie here's
okay
what do you think mama you want to join
in on you want to go in on this one
together
you can come into the coffee koozie with
me
what if we get caffeine poisoning
through our
like what if we absorb too much caffeine
through our
skin and die did your scientists check
that
we'll we'll talk about that later i'm in
marble you in
we got a deal all right we got a deal
dean
thank you my guy great pitch
i love it great pitch right coffee
koozie
what you don't like that probably you
want to go to coffee koozie
listen we can we can hop in i got a
coffee koozie being delivered today okay
because we said yes
so we can hop in the coffee koozie later
and we'll talk about the details of of
the situation all right you'll get
you'll get
some time in it all right you'll get
part of the
the equity too we'll share it all right
good job
next pitch oh we got a vertical video
toilet buddy it's a net a circular net
that you
put in your toilet to catch your change
and
your wallet from falling into the toilet
formerly known as toilet guard
toilet sponge it's a hollowed-out sponge
it's
more absorbent softer than toilet paper
ideas they're not easy
everybody has to go to the bathroom okay
thank you
uh what a great pitch honestly you seem
like you're in a hurry i hope you got to
wherever
wherever you had to go on time because
you literally ran into frame and
were out of breath uh i feel like i've
heard that before
marvel have you heard that pitch before
like that exact same pitch
maybe on a tv show in an office
somewhere i don't
no you haven't all right maybe it was
maybe it's just deja vu honestly i like
it i like toilet ideas
so toilet toilet guard toilet buddy
you know it catches your loose change
your items that fall out of your pocket
because there's a net that goes
underneath your butt when you're going
to the
i see no problem with this i see
literally no problem with this and i
would totally invest in it
although i don't know how much money you
need
uh i also don't know your name and i
would i don't i want one of the products
so here's what we'll do okay this is a
stipulation
all right if you can get me a prototype
in the next five minutes
actually the next 20 minutes because
once we're done with this podcast i'll
go test it out
and uh if i'll i'll i'll give it a
little test run and if we like what we
see here
you got my money all right you got my
money as long as this is your idea and
it wasn't stolen directly from a
television show
but i doubt that that's the case
so yeah well well done great pitch yeah
i liked it
i liked it i liked it a lot
oh i see a gaming chair
hello sharks are you tired of reporting
passing around doing nothing
introducing cataway cutaway is a
heavy-duty drone-type aircraft that can
lift your cat
up to speeds of a thousand miles per
hour hundreds of micro fans built into
the device lifts it up with ease
to start just set your cat under the
vise press the start button
here and watch your cat fly away like a
bird oh my god that cat's flying can
reach heights up to 20 000 feet
iggy's can also be used but if that
iggy's name is peach it won't work she's
too fat so who's ready to
kind of is not responsible for damage or
death if damage or death has occurred
suck it up
okay you threw your xbox like five times
for this pitch
uh man 10 out of 10 pitch the
showmanship is absolutely through the
roof here literally
and figuratively okay this xbox went
flying like three different times in
that pitch so
uh you got my attention there uh
man i would love to see pets be able to
take little
uh rides in their aircrafts you know
if they need to go surveil things
marbles listen imag you know how you
bark
and stuff when you go out front and go
out back and you hear things and cars
and people
and noises and you bark them imagine how
much more fun you'd have barking if you
were up in the air
oh sorry you've been up in the air
before okay
you can go up there in your own drone
now what do you think of that
do you like that idea
no yes peach would first of all
peach would be able to get on that thing
but she wouldn't use it to surveil
or to escape she would use it to find
food because although she is not
overweight anymore she would love to be
so uh as you know if it's iggy if it's
iggy friendly and marbles can get on it
too listen i'm all ears all right
you send me a prototype and uh
and we got we got a deal here all right
i
i don't know how much you asked for i
don't know if you actually asked for any
money
but presentation was so good i don't
even care you can have my money
right marbles they can have our money
they can have it
it's theirs as long as we get one drone
and maybe some some return on our cash
well done i hope your xbox is okay after
all that
uh
anyway squarespace it's a great way to
build a website guys
uh if you ever considered building a
website for your
your own personal business for uh an
event
for any any amount of different things
in your life that you would ever want a
website for squarespace makes that
easy for you hey bud you can relax uh
there's a lot of different things about
building a website that squarespace kind
of breaks down into a really easy
process
uh in addition to that they have an
awesome live chat function with
award-winning customer support 24 hours
a day seven days a week
so you can hop on and get some
assistance uh
from squarespace's help team and they
will they will walk you through whatever
you're going through
whatever you're trying to build your
website uh and
there are also so many different
templates that you can choose from to
really make
the website feel like your own uh
there's a drag and drop interface that
makes it feel
so simple uh and also guys keanu reeves
uses squarespace so that kind of is the
pitch
so try it out go to squarespace.com get
give it a free trial and see how you
like it if you decide you want to uh get
a website
use code uh well go to the url
squarespace.com or click the link down
below in the description here
wherever you're consuming this podcast
to save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain
live it dream it do it with squarespace
check them out also guys
stitch fix imagine that
every clothing store that you shop at
already understood
what you love in clothes okay what you
prefer to wear
what you know you look good wearing okay
that's what stitch fix is it's an online
personal styling service
that finds and delivers clothes shoes
and accessories that fit your body
budget and lifestyle
so to get started go to stitchfix.com
jenna julian
set up a profile set up your size and
uh the styles that you like how much you
want to spend
on each item and you are good to go all
right there's no subscription required
you can sign up to receive scheduled
shipments or get your fix whenever you
feel
you're ready for some new clothing
personal styled
clothing okay so their styling fee is
only 20
which is automatically applied towards
anything you keep from your shipment so
you try them on at home no pressure you
see how items fit
okay and you only pay for what you love
so if there's something that you didn't
love you send it back
and you only pay for what you kept so
right now go to
and stitchfix.com save an extra 25
when you keep everything in your box
check it out or
hit the link down below
good stuff stitch fix all right we got a
few more pitches here
i'm completely out of money but i really
just want to keep investing because you
guys are really blowing me away with
these pitches
all right here we go another vertical
one
hello shark thank you so much for
meeting with me my name is kyle from
massachusetts and i am here to unveil my
latest new revolutionary
designed to help kids learn the alphabet
using one of the biggest memes of all
time
introducing doing it with the alphabet
yes doing it with the alphabet is a set
of flash cards designed to help kids
learn the alphabet using one of the best
memes in modern day history
the doing it to a meme so some examples
on these flash cards include
doing it to a doing it to b
doing it to c and if you fast forward a
little bit
we'll get to such cards as doing a 2k
doing it to l and most importantly
doing it 2m now if you're wondering
about the science of these sets
no need to worry we have tested this set
on a number of
baby and it has shown significant growth
remember a
baby okay so if you're
all interested in investing all we're
asking is
well just a meal just a little bit of
food for us over here because we are
starving and yes we will get to work on
setting out doing it with the alphabet
to every single child in the entire
world
so make sure you invest right now do we
got a deal
friend got a deal shake my hand ken from
massachusetts i think your name is ken
dude wow
what a pitch man i am so excited about
this idea and i love that you
i think i think you said you tested it
on baby
or infant or something and i find that
to be so smart
okay this is a learning tool this is a
game and a device
that's meant to help people
at a very young age a developmental
tool to help them learn the alphabet
such an important thing to know
and to do it with fun and memes
also man the doing it to m line that
just that sells the whole product so
you tell me what food you guys are
hungry for i don't know how many people
you have on your team
hopefully we can afford to send you uh i
don't know
maybe a little bit of food keep you guys
going over there but if that's all
you're asking
you got a deal right marble doing it 2m
doing a a doing it to b fast forward to
doing it to
m i like it i also wonder
like if that is a child's first exposure
to the alphabet
how like truly how [ __ ] up will they
become
that every single time they think of any
letter ever again in their life they're
going to think of that meme
because i like that nice
nice that's what i'm talking about well
done
great pitch great pitch 10 out of 10.
wow all right
we go hello shark hi my name is brenna
france
and i want to pitch my idea for
windshield wipers for your glasses i'm
having glasses myself i've always wanted
some way to be able to see when it's
raining and i'm walking on the sidewalk
these could be installed we could sell
them separately in the store
or we could partner with the
manufacturers of glasses
and have them as an option like blue
light filters and stuff for your classes
when you purchase them
okay um i'm open to give you 100
of my company oh for 2 billion
or a 7 7
royalty fee for every pair of glasses
made wow these demands
and then she was gone that was a lot of
money that you just asked for
i don't have that kind of money and i uh
seven percent royalty
of every pair i'm gonna be in debt for
the rest of my life
although i do like the idea i like the
idea of having
electronic little mini wipers on the
outside of your glasses to go
when when it's raining right so it
brushes away the rain
uh here's my counter offer okay i'll go
into business with you if you
expand past just having the rain wipers
but we also offer inside wipers
on the inside of the glasses for when
you really are crying a lot and your
projectile tears are getting in the way
of your vision
and clouding up your glasses then you
will have
on the inside it will detect sadness and
tears
and it'll come right here and it'll wipe
away the tears
so i think we should have
rain guards and tier guards okay
we should offer both uh both
individually
and as a bundle okay
and if you bundle them together and put
them on your glasses they only weigh two
pounds per lens
so it's really not too bad if you think
about it
and uh at the very least it's a nice
little neck workout
i don't have the kind of money uh
something billion dollars that you asked
for although i mean you sound like
you're fun to work with
maybe you could take maybe you could
take my idea okay
to expand the business and let me know
your answer if you'd like to uh
take this pitch into a different tank
and we'll make a lot of money
all right i don't know i like i just
like the
and how do you power them what's the
battery are they solar powered what
happens if you live in alaska when
there's like
a couple of months where you never see
the sun do we just
we won't ship to alaska then maybe
yeah we won't ship to alaska
[ __ ] it we're never shipping to alaska
even in the summer no no alaska can't
have this product
uh well done thank you for the pitch and
uh i'm in
100 i'm in let's do this let's get
cracking baby
all right next pitch here we go
hello shark hi my name is kate spelled
k-e-i-g-h-t
have you ever taken a bath before if you
have you understand the sorrow that
comes when the bath water becomes cold
introducing blow me simply plug into the
wall socket
and then insert in your bath you'll
become toasty immediately
now critics say it resembles a blow
dryer and sometimes
even a toaster but no it's not either of
those things it's blow me
okay um my asking price
anything i have some unrelated lawsuits
unrelated don't worry but please
give me your money you sound like a
straight-up person
okay and i trust you automatically uh
i'm inclined to give you some money i
want to help you cover those legal fees
of whatever you're dealing with that
sounds completely unrelated that you're
definitely the victim of
the product scares me but i kind of like
it
right you said it it looked
it resembles a blow dryer and a toaster
oven
you put it in the bath and plug it in
i'm not an electrician nor am i a
scientist
uh but i think that sounds like a good
idea because trust me i've been in a
bath
and when that water gets lukewarm and
then starts to make its way to cold
you just you would rather not be in
there anymore
but 20 minutes ago when you were in
there it was wonderful it was hot
your muscles were loosening up you were
relaxing and then all of a sudden it's
just lukewarm and you just feel like
you're
you're just in like nasty cold
filth water so shock me up all right
shock me up with this
uh maybe we could rebrand it the name
might the name might cause some problems
but the product seems honestly the
product seems
fine to me i don't see any issue with it
whatsoever
yeah no i like the product i'm in i'll
give you some money
uh good luck in your legal battles with
whatever you got going on
i hope you can get it sorted it really
sounds like you did nothing wrong
and uh thank you for the pitch
right thank you for that pitch all right
last pitch of the day
all right last pitch of the day in dink
tank
we go our idea
is wheelies fire
to jet packs in your wheelies
press the button you got regular shoes
yeah yeah and you across the bottom
roller skates bar but with jet packs in
it
but with jackpots
[Laughter]
you gotta get to work with your parks
you gotta get to work
you got your jet packs you don't wanna
pay for that uber
[ __ ] that uber but with jetpack but with
jetpacks
that's our [ __ ] that's our idea
but with jet packs uh you guys get my
money
i was the best pitch of the night i just
love how many times you both said
butt with jet packs because literally
any pitch any sentence
is improved when you add but with
jetpacks
okay i like how the pitch morphed too
because i've
i identify with that right where you
start a pitch as one thing and then by
the end of it you've kind of pitched a
completely different product
at the beginning you were you were
marketing uh i believe you were saying
heelys with fire
i love it and then at the end it was
roller skates with jetpacks
but with jetpacks and i like all of it i
just like all of it
i like the i like the energy i like the
pitch
and i like when you end a sentence with
a butt with jet
packs so whatever money you guys want
you got it okay i'm in you won me over i
also i hope whatever meal you were
sitting down for here
was yummy uh i don't know where you
i feel like i could hear other people
maybe this is just your house
but regardless i hope you guys had a
great evening thank you for your pitch
but with jetpacks actually you know what
that's
that should be the name of the company
but with jetpacks and then you just sell
jet packs for every little thing that
you would want to put a jet pack on
of all different sizes but with jet
packs that's the name of the company
brilliant i'm in i'm in
i love it now i want jet packs on my
shoes and my phone and my water bottle
and my dogs
maybe not my dogs well
thank you for your pitch thank you
everyone for your pitches today
oh it was a productive day in the tank i
will say
i think we're going to make a lot of
money but
me and you we went in on pretty much
every one of those pitches i know you
didn't agree to it but
uh you know i talked to your accountant
and i think we can
we can swing it you and me i think we
can swing it
uh well anyway thank you for
hanging out and um hanging on the dink
tank with me this was a lot of fun
um i'm hoping that all of the uh
the audio of the pitches were
much better to listen to and it was part
of the computer audio
and uh the routing of my mic rather than
me holding up
a freaking iphone over my mic so i hope
that worked out better
and uh actually like being able to do
this has
opened up quite a few possibilities to
be honest like we've talked about
uh and when i say we i mean like me and
you guys on stream and also in the
discord there's been a lot of
really helpful discussions and comments
about what i should do in the podcast
and there's been talks about having you
guys on as live guests there's been
talks about having
uh some of my friends on as guests both
in like
video form but audio form but in general
it's just kind of really cool to be able
to uh
i don't know be able to record a
conversation or record a video that i'm
watching or something like that right
i'll be able to do a lot more with it
that way so
i'm glad we did it and i i'm completely
broke now i've given all of my money to
you
uh everyone who entered the ding tank
today but i really do believe i have a
strong feeling that
i'm gonna make that money back because
you guys are smart and these are great
ideas and i don't see anything getting
in the way of
these ideas making all of us very rich
very very rich especially
but with jet packs
uh anyway thank you guys for listening
watching
hanging out with me on the podcast today
i hope you
got some enjoyment out of it uh we'll be
back
next week marble you're gonna be back
next week you gonna join me my guy
[Music]
you gonna join me i'll be back next week
with another episode
uh i do encourage you to keep um hitting
me with those ideas
in the discord and in the youtube
comments here
uh our discord is uh really really
awesome we have
kind of a bunch of different sections
for a bunch of different things one of
which is the podcast suggestions group
so you guys can jump in there
and leave your suggestions but anyway
thank you so much for joining me i
appreciate all of you and i hope you
have a wonderful week i'll see you on
the next
podcast peace
[Music]